Aaron is in Minneapolis hi Aaron welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Thank You mr.
Ramsey it's honor and pleasure to be
able to speak with you how are you today
sir
better than I deserve what's up in your
world oh well my wife and I are seeking
your guidance we think that we probably
need to sell our home to be able to
ensure our overall financial peace in
the future
we've been on baby step 2 for almost the
past three years we've already paid off
roughly 160 thousand dollars are for
what was that we have about everything
student loans new car that we got rid of
a couple lines of credit some visa cards
remodeled house you need me yeah we did
too much and so now I'm about the year
I've left we have about 53,000 left
what's that we estimate that we should
be what's left is remaining on my last
student loan okay and so you're
estimating what a year yeah we're
looking at being out of that hopefully
by this year we're targeting probably
october/november I'm planning on coming
down and seeing you cool all right I'm
with you so we're on a thirty-year fixed
and we looked at the numbers and a
15-year fixed rate for us on what we owe
which is roughly around 370 at our
current income that puts us over 25% of
take-home and I'm not expecting that my
income is going to go up in fact for our
family I'm actually hoping to be able to
change positions here in the next year
or two because currently I'm required to
travel for work and I young children I'd
like to be on with family that's kind of
an important thing for us and so we
think that probably the best move for us
at this point is to sell our home get
out from wonder at this debt and rent
until we clear baby step to build up
baby step 3 and then build up a nice
little down payment before we reconsider
purchasing we just wanted to get a sense
from you if that's wise and we love this
home we bought it we remodeled it
significantly but realizing now that we
put ourselves in a position
occasionally Network right now I make a
little over 200k but and there's a bonus
on top of that but that's variable and
what would it would it drop if you
dialed it back a little it's not quite
clear up most likely getting off the
road I'd probably be closer to the mid
100 150 160
I wouldn't sell today you've made such
phenomenal progress with the house
sitting there mmm and you really have
done very very well you make really good
money you have the ability to make
fabulous money obviously and I would
finish getting out of debt and I would
sit there and you like the house the
only thing that's bothering you is the
numbers the numbers are not completely
out of control they're just not great
you know they're just kind of there on
the bubble you know it's nothing it's
just nothing would we go buy this house
today in this situation no no but you're
there you love it when you move it's
emotionally and financially very
experienced expensive mmm
and so it's the last thing I do to get
people to get ahead and it's not that I
never tells people to move but it's the
last thing and your payments okay for
today so what I would say is this I just
finish out your baby steps keep them
keep playing through the baby steps and
make your adjustments to where your home
more and then let's visit that budget
and look at it and go okay now how
messed up is this situation now and I'm
talking like what two years from now
sure is that you're going to revisit the
discussion I would table this for two
years if I were in your shoes okay
that's helpful thank you because I think
I think you just got an incredible
income the ability to earn you've got
some options here and you've had just
fabulous progress over the last three
years which tells me that you guys are
you know you're doing this you the two
of you are working together you're
talking this through and and again a
part of this equation is you like the
house yeah and you can you're pretty
emotionally invested in it I know that
because anytime you do a renovation it
takes part of your heart to do that as
well as your wallet mm-hmm because it's
a pain in the butt so um you know I I'm
staying if I'm you for two more years
and then I would visit it and go okay
this incomes dropping down to one
quarter we can't get ahead we're going
to be stuck in this thing it's just too
much house and you know in order for me
to be home more and not on the road all
the time
we just can't live in this house and
that's your two year decision or you
look at you go well look at their income
didn't drop as much as we thought I'm
home everything's going good we actually
can do the 15 and continue to fund our
retirement so we'll just we're just
going to stay and I think that's what's
going to happen here because you you
guys have done so well that I think
you're gonna I think you're going to
push through on this I think the numbers
are going to end up working out that's
my that's my prediction we'll see how it
works out I'm not no guarantees on that
but I don't think it's going to hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim
Oh